the story you're about to see is true as  far as I know when I was a child I was  obsessed with changing myself I don't  even remember how I used to be would you  find it  what matters is what it says I've met  two very special people  excellent coats don't you trust me mrs.  G who was the most beautiful woman I had  ever met  no bad horses only bad riders I was  someone I was there  hello mrs. G up in the south see what  you could do I only remember them why  can't I remember myself strong body  strong mind strong body strong mind I  found some pictures from that summer  you're so special you know I have a lot  of regrets  you talked about the relationship but  this is a grown man this was important  to me  why are you so angry why are you not  angry it was pushed yourself  anyone  [Music]  I'm trying to figure out why you  deceived yourself why are you telling  the story Jenny it's my life why you  don't know what's about to happen  [Music]  you